[Musique]
les animaux malades de la peste un mal
qui répand la terreur mal que le ciel
dans sa fureur inventa pour punir les
crimes de la terre la peste
puisqu'il faut l'appeler par son nom
capable d'enrichir en un jour là cayron
faisait aux animaux la guerre ils ne
mouraient pas tous mais tous étaient
frappés on envoyait point d'occuper à se
chercher le soutien d'une mourante vie
nul men excitait leur envie ni lui ni
renard les pieds la douce et innocente 3
les tourterelles ce fuyait plus d'amour
d'habitants plus de joie le lion un
conseil it
mes chers amis je crois que le ciel a
permis pour nos péchés
cette infortune que le plus coupable de
nous se sacrifient aux traits du céleste
cours ou peut-être il obtiendra
l'aguerrissement comme une l'histoire
nous apprend quand de tels accidents ont
fait de pareilles dévouement nous
flattons dans points voyons sans
indulgence l'état de notre conscience
pour moi satisfaisant mais appétits
gloutons
j'ai des voiries force moutons comme
avait-il fait nulle en france même il
m'est arrivé quelquefois de manger le
berger je me dévouerai dont s'il le faut
mais je pense qu'il est bon que chacun
s'accuse ainsi que moi car on doit
souhaiter selon toute justice que le
plus coupable péri si dit le renard vous
êtes trop bon roi vos scrupules font
voir trop de délicatesse et bien manger
moutons canaille cette espèce est ce un
péché non non vous leur fit seigneur en
les croquant beaucoup d'honneur et quant
aux bergers l'on peut dire qu'il était
digne de tout mauvais temps de ces gens
là qui sur les animaux se font un
chimérique empire ainsi dit le renard
est flatteur d'applaudir
on nous a trop peu profonds dire du
tigre nil
pour d autres puissances les moins
pardonnable offense tous les gens
querelles jusqu'aux simples matin aux
dires de chacun étaient de petits seins
l'âme 20 à son tour edit j'ai souvenance
qu'on après deux moines passant la fin
l'occasion l'herbe tendre et je pense
quelques diable aussi me pousse en
jetons 10 de ce prix la largeur de ma
langue je n'en avais nul droit puisqu'il
faut parler net à ses mots au cria haro
sur le baudet un loup quelque peu
claires ou va par sa harangue qu'il
fallait dévoué ces maudites animal ce
teulé c'est bien le doublé tout le mal
ça peccadilles fut jugé un cas pendable
manger l'herbe d'autrui quel crime
abominable
rien que la mort n'était capable
d'expliquer son forfait
on le lui fit bien voir selon que vous
serez puissant ou misérable les
jugements de cour vous rendront blanc ou
noir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]